we have a voicemail number that is 2192
david p
i got a voicemail from our friend dr
eric
dr eric has two theories
about donald trump's coronavirus both
logical let's take a listen
david how you doing man dr eric holland
from new jersey
called a couple other times i've treated
a lot of cobit
in the hospital um i wonder what you
think about
the idea that trump actually tested
positive a while back
and they were hedging and planning on
never even disclosing it to the public
and hoping they would luck out and never
have to and it was only after he started
getting
sick that they said there's no way we
can do this and they conjured up he just
tested positive and oh now we're
bringing it into the hospital uh
preventively proactively
yeah i think that that we're gonna get
to the part two of dr eric's voicemail
that explains a lot of things it
explains why doctors won't answer
when trump had his last negative test
because it probably wasn't
the day you know tuesday the day of the
debate last week
trump showed up too late to be tested
and they went on the honor system the
idea being oh we tested him when he got
on air force one and he tested negative
in all likelihood he wasn't tested it's
even
possible that he had already tested
positive by that time that would explain
it when we wonder
why was trump given treatments that are
usually only given further into the
course of the disease like dexamethasone
when donald trump got it on like day two
of his treatment well
maybe it wasn't really day two maybe
that was actually day six or day seven
so what dr eric
suggests explains a lot of the
irregularities let's continue i don't
know that to me
i wouldn't put it faster the other thing
is he does not have
a cake of coronarius or some
non-descript coronavirus illness
he has cloven ammonia dn normal cat can
they would have said so so
he's got pulmonary bilateral ground
glass opacities
and he's got high inflammatory markers
crp otherwise they would have said they
were normal
he had a fever low oxygen that's copic
pneumonia
and they they're really not disclosing
it that way yeah so dr eric i i believe
is completely right here during the
press briefings with dr
sean connelly conley dr uh uh the doctor
for donald trump
uh he very vaguely said that trump scans
and and
x-rays you know whatever imaging they
did that it
all was in line with trump's health
status and the progression of his
disease and then when he was pressed to
say well
does it show pneumonia does it show
irregularities the doctor didn't say
and so of course dr eric is right if
they were able to honestly come out and
say
every scan was the scan of a completely
healthy person
they would have done it because they're
desperate to make trump look super super
healthy
i think that dr eric is completely right
here
it's speculative but you heard it from a
doctor there and it coincides
if you have an understanding of
propaganda you would likely come to
those conclusions
dr eric has the benefit not only of
being a listener
to this program so that he understands
the propaganda component
as a doctor he also understands the
medical component and the implications
of the symptoms and the medications and
the timeline and progression of the
disease
well said dr eric thank you for the
insights tonight
is the vice presidential debate between
kamala harris and mike pence
there was question as to whether it
would happen there was question as to
whether there would be plexiglass
separating the candidates the harris
team said let's have plexiglas this is a
highly infected white house mike pence
was exposed at the amy coney barrett
super spreader event
and the pence team refused and said we
don't want plexiglas if kamala wants to
bring her own
she can bring her own well as of this
morning everybody has agreed to
plexiglas
it's very very clear that what happened
over the weekend in the debate between
lindsey graham
and jamie harrison where jamie harrison
brought his own plexiglass
and it just looked bad it made it look
like lindsey graham doesn't care and
isn't taking coronavirus seriously
clearly the pence people realized why
are we fighting this we're going to do
more harm if we continue fighting the
plexiglas so we will have a with
plexiglas
debate tonight the debate starts at 9 00
pm eastern but i have a suggestion
join me for the pre-debate show with
your comments and questions and a lot of
different things i will also be debuting
a new
um a new song that i think people will
very much enjoy
i will be live starting at 8 30 eastern
maybe even 8 20 eastern on youtube
and twitch youtube and twitch join me
there for the debate tonight
before that we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today the united states
supreme court
is again reviving criticism of gay
marriage
we will talk about the latest bombshell
report about child
separations at the border and we will
talk about how the
senate majority being in the hands of
democrats or republicans
after all is said and done on november
3rd
the senate majority may now hinge on
a sexting scandal in north carolina
not everybody agrees it's a scandal but
some people say that it is a scandal
we will discuss all of those stories and
much more
on today's bonus show get access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
otherwise i will see you tonight for the
vp debate
live stream don't miss it